o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
a diversidade e inclusão um tema cada
vez mais presente no dia a dia das
pessoas e que toca cada uma de maneira
diferentes e um tema presente no meu dia
a dia praticamente a metade da minha
vida e que me toca profundamente e toda
vez que eu falo para alguém que eu
trabalho com diversidade inclusão é
comum eu ouvi dois tipos de reação
aquela mais romântica nossa seu trabalho
deve ser bem gratificante né você deve
ver coisas incríveis e aquela mais
dramática Nossa esse assunto em é
difícil né você deve encontrar muitos
problemas é claro que eu já vivenciei
situações maravilhosas e situações
horríveis e lamentáveis mas para mim
esse assunto é mais amplo e abundante
ele é como a imensidão do mar e hoje eu
tô aqui para te convidar para explorar
um pouco esse mar comigo como uma
expedição mesmo sabe e eu quero começar
a falando sobre nem se dão de cima a
diversidade como esse
e da condição humana portanto que
descrito a minha você EA todas as quase
8 milhões de pessoas existentes no mundo
nós somos uma mistura Surreal de
características que nos torna únicos e
repetíveis não sei que é uma pessoa
igual a outra nesse mundo ou nesse mar
mas legal você já parou para pensar o
que significa na prática no cotidiano do
nosso dia a dia
se você por exemplo eu arrisco dizer que
você do jeito que você é aonde você vai
você deseja acolhimento respeito e
empatia das outras pessoas mas você não
quer só isso você quer crescer se quer
aprender ter oportunidades você quer ser
útil você quer se realizar é um Eu quero
existir Mas eu não quero só isso eu
quero sentir que eu existo não é assim é
assim comigo e eu acredito que assim com
todas as pessoas também mas nós só
queremos isso porque nós somos seres
sociais e vivemos em comunidade é na
comunidade que nós vamos formando a
nossa visão de mundo que vamos
aprendendo valores de sensibilidade que
nos ajudam a conviver com as outras
pessoas e ela comunidade que nós vamos
construindo a nossa história
O problema é que no mar da diversidade
as comunidades são como Ilhas que
valorizam e aceitam algumas
características e que ignoram ou
menosprezo outras características a
nossa formação ela é baseada em padrões
normativos que definem quem serve e quem
não serve e sem perceber fixados nas
nossas ilhas de referência nós vamos
criando o configurações de convivência
que diz consideram a imensidão de cima
há 20 anos eu tenho explorado muito um
dos oceanos esse mar o Empresarial todas
as empresas desejam algum tipo de
transformação no seu jeito de ser e
fazer por meio da valorização e gestão
da diversidade o desafio entornar esse
desejo realidade está nas decisões
diárias porque essas são tomadas por
pessoas que estão em alguma medida
fixadas nas suas vendas reference
É mas o problema está nas pessoas a
solução também está porque são as
pessoas que morrem tudo e o que eu tenho
aprendido sobre elas nesses anos todos
também é sobre mim e é por isso que eu
quero compartilhar três aprendizados que
tenha ajudado explorar esse mar e que eu
acredito que podem te ajudar também o
primeiro deles é que todos nós temos
medo da diversidade
e lá no final dos anos 90 ainda
estudante de serviço social eu estagiava
uma instituição e lideravam um projeto
que encaminhava pessoas com deficiência
intelectual que o mercado de trabalho na
época o número de empresas que
contratavam pessoas com deficiência era
quase zero sabe quando você vê uma
oportunidade real de tornar o mundo
melhor eu tava muito entusiasmada então
eu idealizei na minha mente e no meu
coração O que aconteceria e eu mergulhei
naquele oceano E aí eu tomei o meu
primeiro caldo
e eu aprendi rapidinho aqui no Mundo
Ideal cabe tudo que a gente quiser mas a
vida real buraco é bem mais embaixo um
de uma mãe me chamou e me disse minha
filha tem 36 anos nunca pegou um ônibus
sozinha na vida você acha que eu vou
deixar ela atravessar a cidade pegar
quatro anos por dia para trabalhar numa
empresa que eu nem sei sequer lá o
gerente estava muito bem intencionado
mas cheia de preocupações com os
clientes como eles vão reagir o que
vamos fazer e os alguns estavam confusos
um deles me disse eu não quero sair da
Extinção eu não quero deixar meus amigos
e eu comecei a brigar se aquilo é dar
certo bem antes de jatinho começar muito
intenção pouca noção o caos se instalou
dentro de mim e ainda uma conversa
franca comigo a minha orientadora me deu
um chacoalhão e perguntou Viviane no
fundo do teu coração você acredita que
isso vai dar certo e para poder
responder com honestidade essa pergunta
eu mergulhei profundo dentro de mim
bom e sabe o que eu descobri
o que eu não acreditava eu acreditava
que eu tava com medo na verdade eu tava
apavorada eu tava com medo de usar
alunos não conseguirem tava com medo de
decepcionar as famílias de comprimento a
imagem na instituição de não ter todas
as respostas eu tava com medo daquela
diversidade mas eu lembrei mais profundo
porque eu queria entender origem desses
medos
Oi e aí pela primeira vez na vida eu
acessei e reconhecia os meus
preconceitos foi doloroso mas Libertador
e para poder sair daquelas ilhas de
referência explorar aquele mar eu fui
prática nós colocamos todas as nossas
expectativas e medos para fora e juntos
nós Compartilhamos a nossa
responsabilidade pelo sucesso daquela
ousadia que na época aquele projeto foi
uma bela de ousadia e os resultados
foram incríveis e pela primeira vez na
vida Eu também experimentei o poder da
inclusão e Mesmo Sem Entender direito em
palavras a sua dimensão o fato que o
aprendi a surfar uma bela de uma onda
nesse mar a primeira delas
e quando eu chego uma empresa é comum
encontrar declarações que se tem uma
diversidade como valor ou que expressem
claramente indiferentes palavras a
mensagem Aqui todos são bem-vindos em
uma primeira olhada é fácil perceber que
há uma lacuna entre o que está declarado
EA realidade as pessoas são muito
abertas ao campo das ideias mas com
dificuldade de materializar em ações
concretas esse desejo elas estão fixadas
nas suas vidas referência todo começo de
um trabalho como eu vi frases do tipo
não temos muitas mulheres porque nosso
processo produtivo demanda muito esforço
físico a nossa processo é muito
arriscado para pessoas com deficiência
ou então somos muito formais então Aqui
as pessoas não podem vir de piercing na
pode ter tatuagem cabelos coloridos ou o
sistema contrário aqui somos muito
abertos mas somos uma empresa jovem
super descontraído então apelidos e
piadas são inevitáveis né algumas
pessoas não se não se encaixam
a e é muito legal durante o trabalho vê
essas frases sendo ressignificados E aí
o que eu quero chegar no segundo
aprendizado
a conviver transforma e eu aprendi isso
presenciando muitas transformações de
pessoas empresas pelas quais já passei e
Claro vivenciando na minha na minha
própria experiência em 2013 Eu Me
inscrevi no programa de intercâmbio para
receber estudantes estrangeiros na minha
casa
e a coordenadora me ligou para me
oferecer uma candidata e logo no começo
da conversa ela me disse que a garota
era muçulmana meu coração disparou em um
segundo eu pensei em meia dúzia de
noticiários que eu tinha assistido na TV
na extrema diferença cultural e nos
possíveis problemas de convivência aqui
na minha cabeça seria um milhares Então
eu fui logo ver fritando disse que não
dava que eu esperava outra candidata e
moça que perguntou mais com problema e
eu não sabia que era problema eu só
sabia que eu não queria então uma
conversa meu marido Charles eu contei do
que aconteceu falei na minha negativa e
ele me olhou incrédulo disse mais o que
que tem ela ser muçulmana Não tô te
entendendo vem cá não és a especialista
em diversidade e inclusão Que papo é
esse que ela não serve e a cada pergunta
que ele ia me fazendo ele ia me salvando
de um baita de um caldo que eu ia tomar
o que juntos a gente decidiu mergulhar
nessa experiência de braços mentes e
corações abertas Osklen Ferber uma jovem
incrível que se tornou muito mais do que
um hóspede mais uma querida amiga que a
gente aprendeu rapidamente a lá e que
você nos ensinou muito sobre a sua
cultura sua religião e como vive dentro
de casa a diversidade já que seus pais
são Imigrantes turcos e ali os irmãos
nasceram e vivem na Alemanha e eu que me
incomodava com as declarações das
empresas percebi que também posso ser
coerente porque nem dentro das minhas da
minha declaração todos também são
bem-vindos a Claudia Werneck da escola
de gente faz uma provocação fantástica
sobre isso ela a pergunta que cabe no
seu todos
Oi e o mais legal é que não importa o
tamanho do seu todos ela disse que o
importante é o tamanho do quanto esse
todos pode crescer com ele transforma
porque traz luz da nossa consciência EA
consciência é a mãe da responsabilidade
é a partir dela que a gente pode se
permitir mergulhar mais profundo e
começar a se sentir parte da imensidão
de cima e aí a gente chega no terceiro e
último aprendizado quando a gente se
transforma o mundo se transforma e 2014
quando a maternidade bateu na minha
porta e colocou a Nina nos meus braços
eu pensei meu Deus que mundo eu vou
deixar para minha filha e eu logo
percebi que a pergunta me fazer a outra
que filha que ser humano é vai entregar
produto então não tem logo meu como
há muita literatura música filmes
brinquedos estimula a convivência com a
diversidade tanto quanto possível e
muita conversa sempre tentando mostrar
para ela que são as diferenças que fazem
mundo ser muito legal e é muito lindo
ver o Charles comigo nessa porque além
de mim ele também têm que editar suas
vidas para poder contribuir Mas ela tá
crescendo tendo outras referências e as
perguntas começaram a chegar eu gosto
desses momentos porque acredito que são
oportunidades para mostrar para ela como
é o mundo e como eu gostaria como mãe
que ele fosse em alguns momentos eu me
sinto bem confortável porque a sua
atenção muito simples mas outras
situações são muito desafiadores como
por exemplo quando ela me perguntou o
que é racismo ela tinha de 5 para 6 anos
e presente uma situação que logo virou
um questionamento e eu disse a ela
linguagem simples que algumas pessoas
brancas maltratam pessoas negras por
causa da cor da sua pele e
Eu Fico revoltada só falava disso com
qualquer pessoa inclusive com as pessoas
desconhecidas e eu precisei acalmar Mais
primeiro eu precisei me acalmar porque
eu pensei será que eu falei cedo demais
sobre isso E aí Nessas horas a gente
está correr para quem entende né
Encontrei o projeto criando crianças
pretas na internet que fala da
importância do estímulo à educação
anti-racista e liguei para minha querida
amiga Estudiosa e ativista miziane Bueno
que sempre me socorre Nessas horas e eu
entendi que não era cedo que como mãe eu
tenho a responsabilidade de mostrar para
ela a minha sensibilidade no assunto e
para ajudar a entender que com criança
branca ela pode e deve tem empatia então
usando também uma linguagem adequada
para a idade eu falei filha calma embora
o racismo exista todo mundo isso pode
mudar e todo mundo pode ajudar inclusive
você e olho para mim me disse série
mamãe como eu
e o respeito amor e carinho todas as
pessoas negras que você convive e todas
que você ainda vai conhecer ela me olha
e diz assim mas então eu já tô ajudando
mamãe
eu não sei se eu usei as melhores
palavras mas eu acredito que a gente
precisa se encorajar para tratar esse
assunto mesmo correndo o risco de errar
porque o risco maior é na educação dos
filhos a gente se calar e o nosso
silêncio perpetuar discriminações e
desigualdades que são frutos do racismo
eu procuro fazer isso com todos os temas
com os quais eu não tem um conhecimento
Total ou que mesmo se tenha eu não saiba
como lidar com ela como criança para mim
isso é transformar o mundo e sabe por
quê que eu escolhi essa história para
ilustrar esse aprendizado porque todos
nós sendo pais ou mães ou não somos
referência na vida de alguém e tudo o
que nós falamos e fazemos ter um impacto
gigantesco na formação e na
transformação de se alguém sendo criança
ou adulto você com certeza você é
referência
se você já parou para pensar que tipo de
referência você tem sido nesse assunto
no começo da nossa conversa eu contei
que muito cedo experimentei o poder da
inclusão Sem Entender direito ainda o
que significava em palavras e depois
desses anos todos eu aprendi que se
diversidade a imensidão inclusão é
movimento é ação e ação com
intencionalidade aquelas são com vontade
dentro sabe de transformar mesmo uma
coisa é fato esse assunto vai chegar em
você e ele pode chegar a como uma
marolinha ou como Tsunami para gente
perder o medo da diversidade é
importante a gente olhar com seriedade
mas também com generosidade para os
nossos medos e reconhecer os nossos
preconceitos
dá para a gente se transformar é
importante a Gente Se permitir conviver
com pessoas que nos tirem das nossas
ilhas de referência e fazer esse
movimento proposital e para gente
transformar o mundo é muito importante
que a gente compartilha e tudo que a
gente aprender sobre esse assunto para
estimular a inteligência e sensibilidade
de outras pessoas influenciam as
mudanças nós estamos chegando ao final
da nossa expedição e eu quero terminar
te oferecendo um presente aí Traz o
pequeno trecho desse livro chamado de
humanismo histórico a humanismo perene
do autor Antonio Meneghetti
o humanismo considera cada homem como
uma criatura única e extraordinária
portanto todos os homens mesmo se
diversos gozam da mesma dignidade sou
homem e nada do que é humano é estranho
a minha humanidade
a aceitação das diversidades é estímulo
portanto humanismo quer e ama as
diferenças Eu acredito com todas as
minhas forças no humanismo na força e no
poder de transformação que há dentro de
cada um e cada uma de nós e por favor
não subestime a sua importância o mar
precisa de todas as gotas para ser
imensidão